[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à new delhi la reine elizabeth a connu
son plus grand succès de foule depuis
son arrivée en inde près de 3 millions
de personnes du temps en compagnie du
prince philippe du président des roues
et des plus hautes personnalités de
l'inde
la reine d'angleterre assistait à la
gigantesque parade militaire destinée à
marquer le 11e anniversaire de la
proclamation de la république indienne
ci-devant colonie de la couronne
britannique parade militaire
impressionnante mais moins sans doute à
cause des blindés et autres armes
modernes pas raison de la couleur locale
qui imprègne cette armée
[Musique]
quant aux éléphants de parade aux
délégations des anciens royaumes et des
tribunes lointaine ils appartiennent
désormais au folklore
[Musique]
le premier britannique lui a passé le
week end à rambouillet où il était
l'hôte avec son épouse du général et de
madame de gaulle pas d'ordre du jour ni
de communiqué officiel mais on imagine
aisément les thèmes de ses entretiens au
coin du feu comme on les a appelés
l'europe bien sûr et surtout les
rapports est-ouest dont l'installation à
la maison blanche du président kennedy
va pour une part conditionné l'évolution
[Musique]
alors
si les robes sont encore aux secrets du
moins les couturiers laisse voir les
chapeaux chez lanvin qu'un stylo un
abat-jour de paille que présente
vedettes de l'actualité produits
mannequin vedette sylvia casabianca chez
jacques griffe est un an de cloche de
plume de vautours que porte marie
thérèse chez jacques aymes capeline à
double usage que portait diana chez
michel goba une élégante architecture de
paris que porte ginai
m
chez pierre balmain c'est au contraire
la réduction qui prévaut compenser il
est vrai par l'ampleur de la voilette
[Musique]
monde réel ou chapeau on peut se poser
la question à propos de ce modèle
présenté par renata chez jean de cesse
et qui répond au nom parfaitement
adéquate de foin coupé
[Musique]
quant au modèle que porte nathalie chez
pierre cardin il tient du suroît pour la
forme et de la gaufrette pour la matière
voici les chapeaux ils sont étonnants
attendant la suite
pour sauver les temples tombeau de
ramsès ii abou simbel l'unesco a lancé
un appel au secours
en effet la construction du barrage
d'assouan fera monter de 62 mètres les
eaux du nil qui engloutiront alors ce
patrimoine de l'humanité
un projet français prévoit la
construction d'une double
semi-circulaire road 2 70 m appelant
très incliné entourant un miroir d'eau
ce projet aurait l'inconvénient de
supprimer à tout jamais l'entrée du
soleil levant qui venait caresser vos
fins du tombeau la statue d'osiris un
autre projet d'une audace stupéfiante
consiste à décapiter d'abord la falaise
dans laquelle sont creusées les deux
temps puis à découper l'europe autour et
sous les tempes a entouré les deux cubes
d'une structure protectrice en béton
armé puis par le jeu de quelques 300
vérins hydrauliques à élever leurs 300
mille tonnes jusqu'au niveau du lac
futur il ferait ensuite recouvert de
rochers pour retrouver leur ancien
silhouette devant les eaux du nil
l'unesco incline vers ce projet a redit
reste l'acceptation de l'egypte et la
question d'argent
[Musique]
sans cesse croissant les besoins
d'énergie oblige à rechercher de
nouvelles sources de production
c'est ainsi que des conduites venue de
lacq passe désormais par la centrale
moderne de montereau le gaz d'aquitaine
relaye le charbon dans l'alimentation de
cette usine qu'un seul technicien suffit
à conduire et où la télévision permet de
suivre la combustion à l'intérieur même
des chaudier
près de chinon s'édifie la centrale
d'avoine c'est l'énergie nucléaire qu'on
va mettre à contribution pour la
production d'électricité
plaçant ainsi la france aux côtés des
nations envoi d'équipement dans ce
domaine
[Musique]
dans l'estuaire de la rance enfin la mer
sera bientôt domestiques et les travaux
qui doivent aboutir à la centrale
marémotrice sont activement poussé
depuis les expériences probantes le nez
avec un groupe décès sur place
utilisant l'énergie des marées dans
quelques mois la france disposera donc
de la première usine marémotrice du
monde
le mouvement des marées puissant
potentiel d'énergie jusqu'ici inemployée
entrera ainsi au service des hommes
[Musique]
si l'on mesure le degré de civilisation
des nations modernes à la quantité
d'énergie elle était consommée par leurs
habitants
nul doute que la france puisse faire
confiance à son avenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
datant de démonstration des petites
cylindrées cette année au rallye
monte-carlo autrement dit avec la petite
voiture pas chère de monsieur tout le
monde
on peut se permettre d'aller aussi vite
et avec autant de sécurité que les
grosses dévoreuse de carburant au long
capot sur des routes particulièrement
difficile comme vous pouvez en juger la
neige n'est qu'un des moindres
traquenard du 30e rallye de monte carlo
il y a également le verglas les nuits
sans sommeil et puis aussi un petit
rayon de soleil très bref cependant à
l'arrivée à monaco
appuyez revient bien vite juste pour le
départ de l'épreuve de vitesse pas de
répit pour les pilotes
la tradition veut que le rallye se
déroule dans des conditions très
difficiles
elles sont encore respecté cette année
seulement pour les grosses voitures
d'essayer de rattraper un retard acquis
sur les routes au fil des kilomètres
les pilotes ne sont pas les seuls à
faire preuve d'audace puis les an plus
tôt on a tous les courages sur la côte
d'azur
et
si la part belle 17 des gagnants encore
bon pied bon oeil après plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres ce sont trois pas
rare qu'ils prennent les trois premières
places pouvant ainsi que les petites
cylindrées qui sont sans complexes
peuvent encore faire mieux que les
groupes
[Musique]
c'est de la main des grâces que les
vainqueurs maurice martin et roger
bateau reçoivent le récompense
[Musique]
l'hippodrome de vincennes à l'heure de
la vérité c'est-à-dire au départ du
grand prix d'amérique
paradoxe pas à cheval américains dans ce
grand prix d'amérique qui est pourtant
la plus grande course du monde de trot
attelé bat cheval américain mais parmi
les grands cracks
une coquette jument normande pas encore
très connue du grand public elle a tout
juste cinq ans et elle se nomme masina
pour acheter cette jument prodige son
propriétaire a tout vendu il s'est
débarrassé de ses boeufs et de ses pairs
et il a bien fait en définitive masina
vous allez la voir
c'est un boulet de canon après s'être un
instant perdu dans le temps l attaque la
ligne droite en troisième position très
féminine elle porte un coquet petit bibi
tout blanc elle ridiculise tous les
mâles dans les derniers 100 mètres et
elle rapporte par la même occasion 20
millions à son propriétaire qui ne
revêtent pas les sacrifices qu'il a
consentis pour elle
[Applaudissements]
après ses victoires du lauberhorn et de
l'âne gamme guy périllat va-t-il réussir
dans la coupe emile allais le triplet
qui ferait de lui un phénomène unique
dans l'histoire du ski alpin malgré la
présence de zimmermann et surtout
d'adrien du billard qui l'année dernière
avait ça le record de la piste un temps
apparemment tabac table et qui est lui
aussi un adepte du vj la fameuse
position française de vitesse le grand
jour le soleil a ramené le sourire
d'emile allais au départ bozon la
qualité exceptionnelle de la neige a
rendu la piste meurtrière au milieu du
parcours après avoir bien négocier le
difficile virage en s opposant aborde le
mur du born et ont rapidement éteint
[Musique]
ce virage en s et le mur du born et dont
la porte est de 60% sont aussi le
tombeau du champion allemand ludwig ce
traquenard du champion italien des néo
colons et de 25 autres coureurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dubillard numéro 9
c'est en partant que son record de l'an
passé a été battu de deux secondes par
l'autrichien zimmermann bien assuré sur
ses skis
ils attaquent impeccablement le virage
en s passe le mur du born et plus vite
que la fée périllat et battant
zimmermann
il prend la deuxième place
[Musique]
enfin guy périr admirable giesser il
attaque le schuss de l'alpe est et
absorbent ces bosses à 110 alain
son temps est déjà le meilleur au
passage de la maison forestière
[Musique]
il aborde le virage en s avec plus de
deux secondes d'avancé sur du billard et
ne dessine que deux virages dans le mur
du born et là où la plupart ont dessiné
quatre et même cinq vira déjà le
meilleur aux deux tiers du parcours
périllat à plus de 110 à leur aborde le
schuss d'arrivée pourtant hérissée de
bosses
guy périllat a réussi un triplé qui en
fait un véritable champion du monde dans
deux minutes 29 secondes 5/10 moyenne 84
kilomètres heure contre 70 km/heure en
1952 par tony seul
[Musique]
pour le boxeur poids welters français
hippolyte annexe le chemin de l'amérique
passe par le palais des sports cette
escale parisienne n'est pas de tout
repos de noir cubain isaac logar son
adversaire n'est pas le premier venu
malgré les encouragements le boxeur
français a beaucoup de mal à déborder
logar
fort bon styliste et boxeur puissant par
surcroît annexes on s'en est rendu
compte sur un crochet au foie
il est allé au tapis pour huit secondes
des admiratrices du français en ont
encore des inquiétudes
[Applaudissements]
inquiétude bien vaine cependant annexes
refait le terrain perdu grâce à une boxe
plus claires et des coûts plus précis un
connaisseur dans les fauteuils de ring
jean paul belmondo match nul pas
d'accord dit on dans le clan français
juliette gréco ne sait trop quoi en
penser
de toute façon un excellent hogarth
auront sans doute une nouvelle fois
l'occasion de se départager
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après 12 jours d'une aventure étrange
l'odyssée de la santa maria est terminée
à la suite de l'entretien qu'ont dit
avoir été mouvementée avec l'amiral
américain smith le capitaine galvin a
finalement cédé il a donc débarqué à
recife les 586 passagers à santa maria
confisqué par le brésil sera rendu au
portugal
quant à henrik également il a trouvé
asile au pays du président quadros
[Musique]
dans le décor futuriste de la toute
neuve capitale du brésil brasilia créé
de toutes pièces dans un désert se sont
déroulées les cérémonies d'investiture
du nouveau président de la république
bien nos poids de ross élu au mois
d'octobre dernier le nouveau président
âgé de 44 ans arrive au pouvoir au
moment où le brésil selon le no2
kubitschek accompli en cinq ans un bond
de 50 ha au balcon du palais de la
présidence
le président sortant josky lockwood
chèque à sous les acclamations de la
foule remis son écharpe à son successeur
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue et bonne chance donc au
président pedros
tout le malheur sur la belgique déjà
depuis ces derniers jours des
inondations provoquées par la montée de
la cendre jeter la désolation et la
ruine dans le borinage plus d'un mètre
d'eau dans les rues et les tristes
spectacles de cette invasion liquide
contre laquelle l'homme est impuissant
mais l'action des pluies devaient
déclencher un sinistre plus tragique un
crassier s'est répandu sur un hameau
près de liège à moulins sur fleuron un
énorme fleuves de boue noirâtre fait de
cendres et de poussières large de 30
mètres et haut de 12 s'est rué sur une
distance d'un kilomètre ensevelissant
tout sur son passage
le roi baudouin et la reine fabiola sont
venus apporter aux populations éprouvées
le réconfort de leur présence et de leur
compassion
plusieurs centaines de sauveteurs
fouillent sans arrêt cet amas de boue et
de cendres une dizaine de maisons
écrasées 11 victimes et plus l'horreur
et la peur dans toute cette région où
les crassiers sont innombrables
tel est le nouveau malheur qui frappe le
peuple belge le voyage de la reine
elizabeth en 1/2 se poursuit avec le
cérémonial habituel
la reine et le prince philip sont
naturellement à les visiter à agra le
célèbre taj mahal véritable poème de
marbre élevé voici trois cents ans par
un radja à la plus chère de ses épouses
à karachi capitale du pakistan
la souveraine a trouvé pour l'accueillir
une aide aux jeunes filles chargées de
ces étranges bijoux d'or on n'a pas
coutume sous le ciel d'occident de voir
ailleurs que dans les vitrines des
musées l'inde derajah est morte mais
elle fait encore rêver
[Musique]
le bond de l'homme dans le cosmos est
pour demain dans le berceau exactement
moulé sur son corps munis de
l'équipement complet avec lequel il a dû
se familiariser pendant des semaines le
chimpanzé nommé anne choisi entre huit
de ses semblables soumises aux mêmes
entraînements a sans le moindre complexe
dans son espèce de sarcophages lexsi
glace pris l'ascenseur pour la capsule
mercury
[Musique]
celle-ci à la pointe d'une fusée
redstone devait l'emporter à la vitesse
de 8000 kilomètres à l'heure jusqu'à 250
km dans l'espace
[Musique]
c'est exactement le futur voyage du
passage et humain que le chimpanzé anne
van hoof et reconnaît la seconde prévue
à 60 kilomètres d'altitude la pointe de
sa fusée se détache
puis c'est au tour de la capsule qui
contient le passager la capsule grâce à
l'énergie acquise continue sa montée
jusqu'à 250 km en a près de cinq minutes
la capsule poursuit sa course dans les
terres al'allure fall de 8000 à leurs
toits rétrofusées coupe son élan et
réduit sa vitesse
elle amorce sa dessins ses fusées leur
tâche accomplie se sépare de l'habitacle
pour réduire son poids et les parachutes
entre temps je tour à tour jusqu'à
l'océan où la capsule est attendue
disons que les pronostics ont menti et
que la capsule est tombée à 200 km plus
loin que prévu
elle se signalera aux patrouilleurs
lancés à sa recherche c'est ainsi que
deux navires la repère et que nous la
retrouvons sur le pont du donneur ou le
berceau de a même été retiré de son
habitacle and bien vivant paraissait
satisfait de cette aventure vertigineuse
qui avait duré trois heures 46 l'homme
dans l'espace est maintenant pour
bientôt
pour demain
[Musique]
au laboratoire d'optique électroniques
de toulouse l'un des principaux centres
de la recherche scientifique le
professeur dupuis vient avec ses
collaborateurs de donner à la science
une arme remarquable au regard de
laquelle le premier microscope
électronique de grandes puissances
construit par lui en 1940 fait désormais
figure de pièce de musée
[Musique]
le nouveau microscope né à toulouse
s'inscrit dans une sphère d'acier de 24
mètres de diamètre
tout le premier étage est occupé par
cette construction sur réaliste un
générateur capable de produire des
tensions de l'ordre de 1 million 500
mille volts
[Musique]
s'y ajoute un canot à électrons colonnes
dans laquelle les électrons sont
accélérées jusqu'à atteindre la vitesse
de la lumière 300 mille kilomètres à la
seconde
[Musique]
enfin lui faisant suite à l'étagé
inférieur sur noté par son coffrage de
protection contre les rayonnements
voici le microscope proprement dit trois
mètres de haut
quatre lentilles 4 tonnes toute cette
masse pour en arriver au petit espace
ménages est au centre de cet élément
une petite surface de quelques 3 mm de
diamètre sur laquelle sera concentrée le
faisceau des électrons
à l'extrémité de cette pointe le monde a
observé dont les éléments sont de
l'ordre du millionième de millimètre
avec ce microscope le plus puissant à ce
jour on aura une vision parfaite de ce
qu'on avait pu jusqu'ici qu'entrevoir et
voici la technique de l'observation deux
caméras de télévision serviront au
centrage du faisceau d'électrons
[Musique]
la mise en place de l'objet à observer
sera naturellement extrêmement
rigoureuse la production de dangereux
rayons x enfin ne permet pas à
l'opérateur de rester sur place
une fois le générateur mise en marche
tout sera dirigée de la salle des
commandes ou les deux récepteurs de
télévision permettront de régler
l'ultime mise au point c'est grâce à cet
instrument qu un énorme pas en avant
vient d'être fait dans la proche de
l'infiniment petit puisqu'on peut en
attendre des grossissements de l'ordre
de 50 mille fois mais c'est peu de chose
par rapport à la possibilité d'isoler du
vide mortelle dans cette cellule
les bactéries à observer
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'équipe du professeur
dupuis a pu pour la première fois au
monde obtenir des photographies d'une
bactérie vivant tu grossis ici dix sept
mille fois
ici 22 mille fois et ici 24 mille fois
l'instantané définitivement visible de
la vie l une à une rencontre de gaulle
bourguiba relance d'une solution au
problème algérien
la réception à l'elysée de monsieur
masmoudi ministre tunisien de
l'information a été l'un des faits les
plus commentées de la semaine
[Musique]
réception du chancelier de nouère marque
est elle une autre relance celle de
l'europe lelangue entretien que le chef
du gouvernement de bonn devait avoir
avec le général de gaulle aurait permis
d'harmoniser les conceptions française
et allemande à la veille de la réunion
des six
[Musique]
les responsables des six pays du marché
commun avaient rendez vous au quai
d'orsay pour ce qu'on peut appeler la
première conférence européenne au sommet
quelle forme revêtira l'organisation
politique de l'europe
rien n'est encore apparents mais l'idée
est en marche
[Musique]
alors me air france avait réservé une
surprise au millionième passager
transporté par caravane c'est ainsi que
monsieur juan espinho de madrid est
devenu en posant le pied sur le sol
parisien propriétaire d'une voiture 1
millions de passagers
c'est pour les caravelles un parcours
équivalent à 493 fois le tour de la
terre à villennes sur seine de paris
les pluies récentes ont miné le sol
d'une colline et une masse argileuse
s'est mise à glisser entraînant tout sur
son passage
un cratère de 20 mètres de diamètre
s'ouvre aujourd'hui devant la villa qui
couronne le sommet de la colline et qui
menace de s'écrouler
l'avalanche qui avance de 2 mètres par
24 heures et qui représente des milliers
de tonnes menace les villas construites
dans la vallée de nouvelles pluies
provoquerait maintenant une avalanche
désastreuse et les riverains jeter dans
une inquiétude compréhensible des
ménages au plus vite de leur immeuble en
péril
[Musique]
la sauvage passe de khaybar l'un des
principaux passages entre le pakistan et
l'afghanistan s'est soudain animer les
montagnards pakistanais étaient venus
saluer une visiteuse de marque
la reine elizabeth qui poursuit en
compagnie du prince philip son voyage en
asie
[Musique]
la passe de khaybar est un lieu
doublement historique qui rappelle de
grands souvenirs
la pacer les armes et d'alexandre le
grand là aussi furent massacrés dans une
embuscade au siècle dernier
seize mille soldats de sa majesté
britannique
[Musique]
ceci n'est qu'une carte mais c'est une
carte suisse petits détails devront
découler toutes sortes de conséquences
plus surprenantes les unes que les
autres
après l'huile de vidange et l'eau froide
l'épreuve de la roue pour laquelle on a
soigneusement choisi un terrain de
boules
mais pourquoi cet acharnement direz vous
c'est très simple si l'on soumette une
carte ordinaire c'est-à-dire imprimé sur
un papier classique à la moitié de ces
brutalités
elle n'y résistera pas tant s'en faut
[Musique]
ce qui est loin d'être le cas de la
première carte imprimée elle sur un
papier à base de fibres synthétiques est
garantie par l' usine qu'ils fabriquent
lavables et corvéables à merci
le papier idéal par conséquent pour les
cartes topographiques les pièces
d'identité
les actes notariés voir les feuilles
d'impôts
[Musique]
mais l'expérience peut aller plus loin
et voici notre carte tordu comme une
corde voué à soulever une voiture avec
ses quatre occupants
[Musique]
s'il reste un doute après tout cela sur
les qualités de résistance de ce papier
on le dit
à taipei capitale de formose les enfants
aveugles ont aussi leurs épaules mais
ici apprendre à lire n'est sans doute
pas aussi facile qu'ailleurs si l'on
songe au nombre de caractères que
comporte l'écriture chinoise
pour le reste les petits aveugle de
taipei s'instruisent comme ceux de
londres ou de paris
les travaux pratiques il est vrai
destiné à les préparer à un métier futur
sont largement teinté de régionalisme à
l'art du tricot
s'ajoute aussi l'art de la presse
et d'autres spécialités sont enseignés
comportant à côté du métier de ma soeur
celui d' acupuncteur comme il se doit
puisque l'acupuncture nous vient de
chine
[Musique]
paysages naïf univers poétique c'est
rousseau ses roues sont toujours cette
étrange petit bonhomme tout seul dans un
monde chargé de secret cette petite
ambre la 1900 de rousseau on la
retrouvera dans ses oeuvres qui valent
aujourd'hui des millions et qui furent
vendues quelques francs
[Musique]
et
là
il naquit en 1844 à laval dans la tour
droite de la porte de jaurès où son père
exerçait le métier de ferblantier et qui
depuis s'est enrichi d'une plaque à son
nom
c'est là qu'il vécut son histoire ses
premières années avant d'entrer au lycée
de sa ville on ne pense pas qu'il y fut
un très brillant élève ses années de
collège le menèrent jusqu'au régime at
il pris part à l'expédition du mexique
où il aurait découvert le goût des
tropiques
c'est peu probable mais il fit la guerre
de 70 et fut paraît-il nommé sergent sur
le champ de bataille ce n'est pas sûr
non plus ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
avait en 1869 épouser clémence boitard
de saint germain en laye pour laquelle
il composa pour mandoline ou violents
cette valse qui n'ajoute rien à sa
gloire il rappelle en même temps du
papier chez un huissier qui l'abandonna
pour entrer dans l'administration de
l'octroi ce livret de tarifs qui fut le
sien l'accompagnant pendant les années
qu'il passa dans la guérite de la porte
de vanves et c'est à cet emploi qu'il
dut le surnom de douaniers dont
guillaume apollinaire devait plus tard
le gratifier
[Musique]
devenu veuf il prit sa retraite et 20
logé dans la pauvre revers singes et aux
rixes où tout est resté comme il le
connu par cet escalier sordide il
montait à son atelier ou s'estompait
toutes les ombres d'une vie médian l'art
maintenant occupe toute sa vie ils
essaient d'ajouter en donnant des cours
quelques francs à sa retraite
proportionnelle mais il est souvent en
dette avec son marchand de couleurs
sa vie c'est le tableau qu'il t'a c'est
la magic réalité de ces évocations c'est
cette jungle qu'il n'a jamais vu qu'à
travers le journal des voyages elle le
mènera à travers son illumination
quotidienne jusqu'à sa mort en 1910 à
l'hôpital necker willener simplement
qu'un pauvres qui meurent parmi les
ports il repose maintenant à laval sous
la pierre ou le sculpteur brancusi
gravats l'adieu d'apollinaire gentil
rousseau tu nous entends nous
apporterons des pinceaux des couleurs et
des toiles afin que tes loisirs sacré
dans la lumière réel tulle et consacre à
peindre comme tu tires à mon portrait la
phase des étoiles
et aujourd'hui cette exposition qui est
la plus importante réalisée jusqu'ici et
dont les 80 tableaux sont assurés pour 8
milliards d'anciens francs n'a même plus
à consacrer le gentil rousseau comme
l'un des maîtres de la peinture moderne
on pourra rêver devant la nasse
[Musique]
on pourra rêver devant le portrait de
l'authie à cette destinée mystérieuse si
modeste dans son acheminement quotidien
si bouleversante dans sa portée
artistique
il avait le don céleste d'imaginer il a
donc vécu son rêve sans se soucier des
rires et des sarcasmes que faisait
naître sa peinture il admirait beau gros
mais il peignait avec honnêteté comme un
gentil rousseau qu'il était et c'est lui
qui en définitive a eu raison
[Musique]
on rêvera donc devant le monde qui a
ouvert ses tares qui ne trouvaient ses
seules certitudes que dans son coeur on
rêvera devant ce petit bonhomme tout
seul dans la vie tout seul avec son
innocence secret
[Musique]
la moitié de la france avec 80 minutes
alors de colombes on a payé 18 mille
francs certaines places de tribunes pour
voir quinze rugbymen français en maillot
blanc opposé au rouleau compresseur
sud-africain apparaît souvent au diable
et même parfois à l'abominable homme des
neiges pas impressionné du tout par la
réputation d afrique en date les
maillots blancs donnent des frissons
joie aux 50000 spectateurs de colomb dès
le début du match le jeu à la diable des
français sème la panique chez les
rugbymen du diable sur un contre kroos
match n'a rien laissé on avait pourtant
pour lui les yeux de chimène dans les
tribus maintenant c'est la panique de
l'autre côté les avants sud-africains
par tarrafal de locomotive lancée à 100
à l'heure il faut percuter sec pour les
arrêter et d'un et de deux et d'autres
pas encore un autre pas le temps de
respirer et du panache avec ce tarif
fixe
on est tenté de trouver un peu trop
téméraires lorsqu'il contre attaque
comme en ce moment de plus dans lignes
de bus quatre femmes de corps et
bouquets numéro 12 mai tous ses
adversaires dans le vent on y croit à la
victoire seulement voilà elle tient à
petit
regardez ce qu'il faut pour manqué un
essai tout fait le petit rancoule est
tout seul
un ford pourquoi faut-il qu'un ballon de
rugby ne soit pas rond ça n'arriverait
pas des choses carrées dans les mêlées
ouvertes on ne se fait pas de cadeau de
toute manière le porteur du ballon ne
garde jamais longtemps
[Applaudissements]
ça chauffe pour effacer
vous avez raison monsieur l'essai n'est
pas marqué une tonne et demie de muscles
en pleine action voilà ce que ça donne
sur un terrain de rugby
mais le rugby est un jeu varié un jeu
magnifique belle attaque française
joliment contré par les springboks ce
qu'ils repartent à leur tour
on n'a même pas le temps de reprendre
son souffle dans les tribunes sur le
terrain non plus mais où est donc passé
le ballon neuf voilà il est pour les
français
la victoire est au bout de cette attaque
si vous êtes cardiaque ne regardez pas
on se demande encore comment cette balle
de match a pu être humain que c'était la
dernière attaque de la partie la france
n'a pas gagné mais tout le monde est
d'accord les rugbymen français sont les
meilleurs du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nouvelle de l'assassinât de patrice
lumumba a fait naître un peu partout
dans le monde des manifestations de
protestation manifestations inspirées
protestation dirigé sans contredit tous
ces cortèges ceux de londres comme ceux
de moscou avait un but identique
l'ambassade de belgique à moscou
cependant monsieur h et est également
rendue responsable du sort du leader
congolais
mais après le caire c'est belgrade qui a
sans doute villa sur le plus violents
menés contre l'ambassade de belgique
la police a dû faire appel aux lances
des pompiers pour tenir en respect les
manifestants
singulier destin que celui de monsieur
lumumba au côté duquel on voit ici
monsieur guy zinc à son continuateur six
mois avait fait de l'homme fort de
léopoldville ce prisonnier convient
traité sans ménagement un jour de
décembre dernier son exécution vient de
rallumer le brûlot congolais
[Musique]
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
monsieur h a été tour à tour vilipendé
par monsieur arin ceux tenus par
monsieur stevenson débats orageux que
devait d'ailleurs interrompre une
manifestation de noirs américains a
sorti deux bagarres et de hurlements
[Musique]
on n'avait jamais vu cela aux nations
unies
le tango n'a pas fini de peser sur la
vie internationale
[Musique]
le 12 février les soviétiques ont lancé
un nouveau satellite
rien de nouveau jusqu'ici mais de ce
satellite est parti en direction de
vénus une fusée qui se rapprochera de
l'étoile du berger après un voyage de
quelque 100 millions de kilomètres
allons-nous connaître le secret de vénus
qui s'entoure d'une atmosphère nuageuse
assez semblable à celle de la terre
apprendra-t-on que la vie est en train
d'y suivre l'évolution suivie par notre
planète que dans ces brumes les premiers
végétaux y sont nés ces végétaux dont on
retrouve les traces fossilisées vestiges
des forêt de fougères arborescentes qui
couvrait notre globe voici un milliard
d'années venus en est elle à ses terres
où la première vie animale se
manifestait dans des marécages et où
dans la merci lurienne apparaissait ces
étranges nautile dont l'espèce n'est pas
morte
résistante à tous les bouleversements à
travers 600 millions d'années alors que
disparaissait d'autres espèces dont les
musées concerne les fossiles
[Musique]
est elle parvenue à ce temps où les
premiers vertébrés les poissons ont fait
leur apparition
poisson cuirassé d'abord puis poisson à
mâchoires dante et lointains ancêtres
des requins ou plus avancé encore au
temps où la vie passée de long sur terre
avec les premiers sauriens souches des
grands reptiles secondaire à moins qu'au
milieu de tarnac gigantesque beaucoup
plus en arrière 15 100 millions d'années
de ted lavie n'en soit encore qu'à ses
premiers balbutiements et que ne
commence à jaillir du monde minéral la
toute première traces d'organismes
vivants avec les premiers virus
[Musique]
le soleil se lève t-il sur une vénus
déjà vivante ou sur une planète sans
autre écorce qu'une mère de méthane
veine usic qui nous dira t-il tout cela
[Musique]
chez fernand aubry le visagiste voici le
carnaval un carnaval qui s'apparenterait
au songe d'une nuit d'été
si shakespeare n'était pas si loin mais
est il vraiment si loin
aujourd'hui les légendes de la forêt
viennent jusqu'à nous dans ces masques
éblouissant qui raconte en dentelle en
perles en branchages en fourrure en
plumes et en paillettes la vie secrète
des faits et des dryades d'un monde que
nous n'atteignons plus qu'en songe qui
ne seraient sensibles à ces silhouettes
en train d'une magie rentrer dans le
secret des choses et qui ne peut
remettre au milieu de nous faut-il le
dire que par l'intermédiaire d'un as
en dix ans orly est devenu le premier
aéroport d'europe continentale avec la
déviation spéciale de l'autoroute
il n'est plus qu'à huit minutes des
portes de paris
[Musique]
jeter au dessus de la nationale 7 sa
piste de 3 km 300 accueille depuis 1959
les plus lourds appareils à réaction
là où voici 35 ans n'existait que de
hangar à dirigeables des installations
s'étendent maintenant sur plus de 14 200
hectares et en gardant la est le plus
grand du monde et des ateliers sont
alignés sur un kilomètre et demi
[Musique]
indépendant des compagnies aériennes
l'aéroport de paris entreprises
nationales qui construit et exploite les
aéroports parisiens achève la nouvelle
aérogare dorny cet immense édifice de
six étages à une ossature métallique qui
pèse plus que la tour eiffel
ses façades où s'harmonisent l'acier
inoxydable l'aluminium et la glace est
maillé ouvre presque 2 hectares au
rez-de-chaussée un rôle de 190 mètres de
long où se succèdent les biches et des
27 compagnies clientes de l'aéroport
attend les voyageurs dans un cadre ultra
moderne pilier revêtus de serpentine et
d'aluminium plafond en lan d'aluminium
[Musique]
l'automaticité est partout porter au
maximum et les portes vitrées du hall
s'ouvrent et se ferment tout seul tout a
été prévu pour accélérer la circulation
des voyageurs aux ascenseurs 20 escales
à tort la possibilité d'un trafic
pouvant atteindre 15 cents passagers à
l'heure au premier étage la galerie
marchande qui conduit aux airs de départ
présente une façade en glace de 170
mètres de long elle apparaîtra aux
voyageurs de 1961 à l'aérogare d'orly
une plaque tournante géante du trafic
aérien l'aéroport de paris a fait appel
aux matériaux les plus modernes acier
inoxydable aluminium et glace
il est dès à présent possible d'assurer
ici la réception de 6 millions de
passagers par an une réalisation à
l'échelle de l'aviation commerciale à
réaction
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]